les stations de lavage sont bondées
après le passage du nuage de sable en
provenance du sahara les automobilistes
yvelinois été nombreux à faire la queue
pour laver leur voiture parce qu'avec là
le vent du revenu du sahara ça une
petite couche de particules de sable sur
la plupart des véhicules dont convient
tous laver notre d'autres voitures ah
oui oui surpris par le monde oui du coup
il ya vraiment plein de gens et c'est la
filiale a que d'attentes là il ya cinq
minutes que j'attends mais je pense que
ça va durer un petit moment je pas si
vous avez regardé les voitures que qu'il
ya sur le parking franchement là l'écart
cher mon faire leur business on n'est
pas pressé c'est dimanche a fait beau je
vais pas passer la journée non plus ici
mais quand il faut il faut donc on passe
sur chacun son tour dans cette station
de lavage deux camps ceux qui préfère
laver leur voiture eux mêmes à la main
et ceux qui préfèrent des rouleaux
automatique en fonction du véhicule là
dessus
lou ça nettoie un peu plus dire de
manière un peu plus propre j'estime et
aussi effectivement un peu être
feignantise
comme ça ça m'évite de me remettre un
peu partout dont la voiture était propre
elle s'est pris le sable donc éviter
d'ailleurs de passer le rouleau avec le
sable avant c'était rouleau ils sont en
nylon et maintenant il sera pas homogène
ils ont voté à tissu donc ça à imola
voiture pour le gérant de la station pas
facile de faire face à l'afflux de
personnes il ya quatre jours et depuis
c'est 24/24 que le säntis tourner et bas
nous on a des heures a pu en finir non
plus en plus en technique chez un petit
peu compliqué parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
assumer l'ensemble au niveau de l'eau on
a un forage mais le forage est tombé en
panne ça fait qu'on a notre ville et on
n'a pas assez pression donc on est
obligé de bloquer une piste sur deux est
une sportive de lavage obligé de faire
une série d'attentats peu près de 2 8 à
10 voitures est on obligé que les
véhicules l'espace de quatre minutes et
pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore laver
leur voiture il est préférable de ne pas
attendre trop longtemps car le sable
peut endommager le moteur et la
carrosserie